welcome back to grandma unfiltered faces
by me Josh Smith and today we are joined
by the oscar-nominated star who's
literally flying without wings
ya ever know it's Felicity Jones now I
love this and you basically the my
cultural life as long as I can remember
shall I go yes what Queen and you're
playing another really powerful role in
the aranaut as a scientific Explorer yes
taking to the skies with Eddie Redmayne
but you played so many amazing powerful
characters in your time what have you
learned about your own power going
through your career I'll say that's a
really good question I didn't I think
you do take a little bit of the
character and you take the bits that you
like anyway but this we're playing
Amelia Ren I think part of what I loved
about her was that she's really
impulsive she doesn't over think she she
acts before she thinks and she said she
sort of takes anything on and I
definitely like to push that side of
myself you know I can be someone who
probably overthinks things a little bit
too much so it was nice to play someone
who's just a bit of a wild cat and
throws caution to the wind so have you
stopped overthinking so much yes
laughter yeah it's gone it's gone yeah
it's like therapy play the right
character and never yeah I never worry
about anything no you know anxiety gone
because also is a film about
self-discovery as much as scientific
discovery
what's your own journey with
self-discovery been like for you and
what would you say been like the bumps
along the way well I think it's all I
mean usually it's kind of the battle
with confidence isn't it isn't that the
thing you find and then when you get
older and you get into your 30s I think
you stop caring so much which I think
that's what's been so nice about the
past few years is that and you get less
self-conscious you still have worries
and you still kind of you know I used to
have really bad get really nervous and
worried about things when I was younger
and you know to the point that I'd sort
of be vomiting before you know doing
certain exams and things like that sort
of terrible anxiety and that's
definitely got better as I've got older
and I think you you just don't sweat the
small thing so much do you because also
in in that kind of trajectory you become
one with your own voice right and this
character makes her voice heard and no
with your own voice how hards that been
to have your voice heard throughout your
career what you're saying what been the
changes in that it's definitely because
I think you always have a voice don't
you and it's just letting that voice
come through I think it's and that again
is another confidence thing isn't it
that the Udo I think is that you don't
have anything to prove to anyone so I
think so much you think you're so
worried about what everyone else is
thinking and then you get to a point
where you go you know you can't control
other people's opinions and other
people's thoughts and they're going to
think what they want to think and you
you have to be you have to be bold
mm-hmm and you kind of have to overcome
your own inner critic as well don't you
yes yeah yeah I think I always think
what it was so nice just to have no
inner critic you must just be so happy
if your lovely life to me it also pushes
you to be your best self and put your
best foot forward I think as well have
you found that yeah I guess there's a
certain amount of um become is like math
achievement that comes from a certain
perfectionism and a certain pressure but
I sort of feel like only gets you so far
and then actually actually to do
anything really creative I think being
too tough on yourself as isn't actually
the best the best way and I think it's
actually the opposite it's a kind of
letting go of that critic that is when
you achieve the really exciting stuff
and you trust the people around you you
know you're not you can't do everything
on your own you can't do anything on
your own it's only in partnership with
other people that you achieve something
interesting because at the center of
this film is an amazing companionship
you have a Bedi's character what has
this film and your personal nation ship
with him taught you about the power of
hanging ship and friendship and what you
can learn from teamwork well I think you
just do really interesting work when you
when you work with people that you
respect to the you admire it makes it
just made it so much easier knowing that
we already have that trust in place it
also makes it fun that you can't bit of
a joke in between you know takes and
things like that and I think you it just
doesn't feel as scary really because
you're building something together so
you're taking you know the
responsibilities together it's not all
on your shoulders and with Eddie it's an
absolute partnership in that way that we
we both kind of take the pressure
together and and and and sharing it
which makes it much easier but as well
because you are stuck on this balloon
for quite a long time and there were
certain moments when you're filming this
when you're a bit like oh my god I just
need my own personal space when you're
playing a role like this which is also
quite challenging in itself you like
you're doing stunts you're dangling off
the edge of balloons you're doing a lot
how do you look after your own mental
well-being would you say you do I mean
this was one of the hardest experiences
I've ever had and physically it was
absolutely grueling I mean to the point
where we were both covered in bruises
and bashed up by the end of sheeting I
definitely self-care was not no not the
order of the day on this one you just
sort of it's a bit like being in the
army I think you sort of just you just
keep going until the end yeah how'd you
look after yourself afterwards
what are your self-care regime I have to
remind myself about self-care you know I
often see my friends and they'll just
naturally be booking kind of massages
and and nail appointments and I make
well I have to do that I have that has
to be part of my life but it doesn't
come naturally at all
but when I do do it I feel much better
about myself but but I think I always
find just exercise is the thing you know
for releasing those endorphins and
keeping you happy and active and fit and
yeah not taking things so seriously I'm
clearing that mind definitely do you
think sometimes just running out I know
and it's free go for a run with a wither
because also in this it's all about I
mean as everything is about life a
journey to make this not like but there
are so many highs and lows in this and
you've had the most amazing career
that's lasted such a long time what do
you think has been below you've learned
the most from in your life and the high
you've learned the most from yeah that's
very good for a film about balloon
England yes
up and down I think I mean in terms of
career I think you you realize that
there's never a perfect job that it's
net you know that it never comes in the
perfect way that they're always gonna be
little compromises but actually it's
what you can do with something and I
think you have to take opportunities
when they're there and then I think the
highs are when it's always when you make
something and it connects and it
connects to you a lot of people that
that's really special and that's sort of
what you're hunting for all the time
what is that magic formula that makes
everyone love something hmm I know
because we were talking about voices and
being heard and like we're saying you do
pay a lot of powerful female characters
is there a time when you've really stuff
to have your own voice heard and you've
been pat yourself on the back of it and
pushed yourself to do it can remember a
time we've done that
yeah I think from actually playing Ruth
Bader Ginsberg who's a pretty formidable
woman she gave me a lot of strength and
I used to get quite nervous about public
speaking and I noticed and she's made
some brilliant speeches and she always
has a little piece of paper with her and
she reads it and I always used to think
you know you got to be completely off
the cuff but I realized if you write
something that you believe in and that
you care about then don't don't you know
who cares if
reading it from a sheet of paper it's
the words that matter and so I
definitely felt from seeing her and and
learning from that but public speaking
doesn't need to be as scary and what
would you say for the audience sitting
out here because we've been talking
about confidence inner voices sciencing
quick in the critics what is the kind of
light empowerment mantra that always
gets you free don't sweat the small
stuff yeah it's an important thing to
remember yeah because we get so bogged
down in these are the really tiny things
and when you actually look back on it
and the perspective yeah I think so and
I think it's um I think often reminding
yourself to probably don't take it all
too seriously I think cuz you know we
don't have that long here it goes super
quick thank you so much doing me your
epic thank you so much for joining us
for another edition of glamour
unfiltered hosted by me Josh Smith and
we will see you in two weeks for another
epic episode of glam I'm filled with
such epic people as mr. T
Jones
you